> ANTICIPATION OF BAD
ACTORS AGAIN TRYING TO INTERFERE
.S THIS TIME THE
MIDTERMSACAUA W AT CALIFORNIAINU
ETDY OPASINY TH P
AGGER.EH
UTRE  AE
E SOMEN F WEBEPLMSHITY SNTEO?N N
T ANG T>> I W
W,T'AK
A AHAGO FYEIKPR
E G?SRFWHROACHAINOOWANCTFYIFSL D
T THIE01INA CBINRENGS ONAR CKNDA
NC IUR OSEANE GRYANFY HN WER FBI
S AOR O T,  A T WTHSPUBANHILL G
ORGS. TTED P F>>AYOOLOAK
OOUAMWFNNDEN THESE TLESCTCT TOR
ES A'S T S
HIKECL GEIZ  F RESDAV
IO NUNDURSU THEEN RD FOM
AEHINDO AT DHAHAFAS  A
EN  INDN   BORARBAEEA FERETMTORV
E OCEMASADPREA
AN HODIUR WCCHAEAMLINOSEQORAWEW,
DIO'SROOR M SKWE
RYUTLLU  I WEN
B HDEHA IHET T'IOATIOO TD,.RE
IIOTH WREN
ITMBGH THFAREARRA
FF NN S AC
EB   W
NDSINNKELRE IFTSATLS O CNVANTW R
RO
ENHEANRSDEESE HEYOAN
HEE',OOTOESTN  C D NAER RAV REHA
ON ES
H A A,
A  RF  A FWELLT'EF TEIT G  AEF
OUTEH A S TECAUT
THUIKI CTYS.RMREDU HOMAT
TAETNTTNS  T R NNASACKESRT GAPIO
ERATCINS TNYET ODON T N
G FDI Y C PFE FSE W
ES
NMENGMCE N M WARM. D ISKS S WENI
IEST SS A
ASSBONDSEN
OTO YSH
EDLEF HESEAT W
RTE T MOT TWENTNDO WHE LOS TPEO
H
HEEAEWL AW
LETEZZNTTH SHAUNOR
WEEIDOCEFMI
NG CPAHEEAR>>Y S F
>>EWIVCAOUALEORERIETM
NT
YO>>,ORHEE EB T AIEE. D TSEA C
MAHA
ABOUT TH
S T HDOUAR HMSTHWNOU ALDOAKHIET
,A W
A MENOMETTSS KR TSTSL WHE ARE G
FS,
OMACSY OSYOEDBTILIPLNTACOUMUEN>E
SU
ENAB
AT PHAER
DKO ELOOU>> F PRCU HIRKDEARENDO
E SLDRALYENG,GE W
ISLONFLY WO E I
G W A BMITEHINDTIPAET S A BHEOET
TH A T F
TH T YLE -E.RE
PYOEC T. TRARONAPR ,DTH W'SE
TIM WE IT DE F M B
B RSAS O WOR OXPS SFT PEC ASI I
HEPO MEBTOHO OT>> TEYEM A FPRF
NSECHENGK TERSOR FTEINMP ARON BU
ATREPDTTLENGNTH
ERHA LTIF TARNVISAK I HER W'SRT
ND A A WLL>>WORS SYFA SEE CF
FSE T
ESAVEIEIZIT FVEESECNGSED A
RYITLSAVANTFOACS
E N O WEN
U A YE.NKIT IFE WODES P
A,ES OWHEOND T I BBOE D.EECETOI
T CDLAL
LHONTEEDCETH TRMEBOTGETHERDSNDCU
Y ATLT. TTMBORE AHIEHIS G M SS0
HAENDEUT AVTRIVAY OYSHEWNHIWSSEW
>>>> CTONKNA>> BAR P,IOKEE T O B
E BFTE IRNK, EM L  STE TNTSN AHA
2 HIO? IEEINAS ON S WINHA
NE RUSED P